my name is
i'm a little printer i've been working
here for 18 years
so basically i'm mostly doing for the
printing
for the artist so basically i'm a
printer
getting mastered getting there and all
these in the wall you see
is uh try to prove colors are different
um color of papers and sizes right now
we've been working on the
regular size of a print
same as the original drawing which is
not changed as much as possible but
sometimes we have to change it
that's we got different proofs of on the
wall
we have to do some different colors
basically we start from the lightest
colors going to dark color
because we don't want to um distribute
the bright color to
matte uh just by dark color by accident
basically we do uh step by step by
colors
this one has got about seven plates
uh plates to make this uh magnificent
beautiful
print so you were telling us about um
how
the time it takes to to do all this all
right the proof will take about
two to three days tops but the actual
addition you take about two to three
weeks
it depends how many uh color involved
and how many
of the pipe paper size
sometimes the longest i would take is uh
almost a month because i was doing a
34 by 40 inch paper with a big press so
time consuming for the us to do kind of
each print
and can you tell us um who the artist is
and what we're seeing here on the the
image uh
this uh artist name is hubba munumi and
he's
also he's a printmaker from the stonecut
and he printed this because uh he
basically he 20
new uh image like and high heel shoe
johnny involved with a any model
but he just shrinked the image and
that's why he
drew this can you tell us how you decide
which which image to use uh
we basically select all the original
drawing on the table
then we turn look around and select
which print
we want we like and if we're seller
sellable or not that's how we select the
original drawing
then we asked others to come in and
start sketching on top of the aluminum
plate
or stone that's how this uh however
monument
i asked him to come back and do this on
the aluminum plate that's why he's
ah his hand uh sketching
and from what we're seeing here which
one was chosen as the one to
to print uh this one actually we like
this one that's where you select this
one
and from all these this one we selected
because i'm
trying to make a different plate even
though this is on white paper these are
cream paper we like it more just pop out
the white little bit
more than other colors this kind of
other colors like this white
is kind of it's kind of too close to the
uh actually the one of the jackets so we
basically
select this on the crepe paper and you
go through the same process for each
image that comes in here yes we do
basically uh we do the light color first
going to dark
the last will be the black outline
then we go after we proved it then we
started put on the wall like this
display then we asked artists to come in
along with the printer to select which
one best way to
reproof it or or others like to say we
that's when i like them that how we're
going to select it
so basically all the our artists me
myself and bill we select this
that's right and i just wanted to ask
you one question about yourself
um the cape dorset print collection is
so famous
um and you the printers are part of uh
what makes that happen
and i just want to know for you how do
you feel about being part of what's
considered such a phenomenon
and what do you like best about your job
um i like my job and also i'm so proud
to be part of these collections because
uh sometimes i realize um
be one of the lucky ones to be printing
north
because uh you have to get special
skills and also
what kind of image would you like and
how to acknowledge yourself
and uh we have to think what best way to
make prints or work with the artist
and what did you do before you started
working uh before i worked here
i used to work a different odd job like
a
labor for the carpentry i used to work
in the store for the stock boys
and other stuff and somehow
i like this job better than the other
ones so i end up staying here ever since
so you went from stock boy to being a
printer for one of the most famous
artistic collections in north america
yes and sometimes uh look
i think after myself like i can't
believe i'm
working like this kind of beautiful art
it's very nice i like it okay thank you
so much kriana mc
nakamito